I'm Nick a design advocate at Google and
I'm James a course developer at Udacity
and I'm Roman also design advocate at
Google if you haven't figured out
already this is a course on Android
design clear compelling design will help
your Android apps stand out in today's
super competitive market take Udacity
Android design course built with Google
to learn how to build beautiful
consistent experiences to delight your
users learn to sort your dips from your
pixels pick the right layouts and
navigation structures and style your app
to match your brand learn the principles
and implementation of material design to
make your Android apps clear simple
intuitive and delightful get started now
your users are waiting for more
information visit udacity.com/google